some kind of
laughing hello everybody my name is
marip and welcome back to Five Nights at
Freddy's Help Wanted 2 we have solved
nothing we have done nothing we have
gone to the lengths of doing a whole lot
of lixi and start over hi welcome back
to Five Nights at Freddy's help wanted
we're going to go back into the sister
location office rendition of the
original Five Nights at Freddy's
experience keep track of Funtime Freddy
he's got important things to say and
we'll send bon bon to keep you
company he's got important
things after careful consideration of
pimus complaints from members of the
program we have decided to modify some
of the program's operational protocols
the modifications were made after
frequency analys is of what words were
still legible after the complaints were
submitted the most frequent of which
were please why children home anything
and Confused in summary a more cheerful
and affable standard of communication
has been established prepare to receive
modified message this video is sponsored
by Han Kai star rail winner of the 2023
iPhone game of the year if you're
looking for a game with engaging
mechanics great characters and an
amazing story then Han Kai star rail is
for you not looking for these qualities
and under no circumstance should you
down download this game through the link
in the description below be advised we
will know play how you want with
strategic turn-based battles for the
tough fights or an auto battle mode for
grinding materials to power up over 20
unique characters each with their own
abilities charms and backstories if you
win everyone
[Music]
survives version 1.6 just released
bringing an all new map new characters
epic story lines and much more and you
can earn 10 free star rail special
passes just by logging in for 7 Days
download the game through the link in
the description below or my pin comment
be advised alternate activity is
currently dangerously High practice
standard screening procedures and always
ensure the validity of the entity you
are speaking with but you can trust
me I am
me download today and until the end of
the version 2.1 update you can receive a
free limited five-star character with Dr
ratio himself use my promo code 2 AQA
294j 537 for 50 Stellar Jades you must
memorize this code do not just copy and
paste it enter it from memory only
explore the story unravel the Mysteries
and fall your Trailblazer into the
darkness to find their connection to the
stellon hunters be advised you do know
what that means your recollection of
such knowledge has been deemed
nonessential you'll just have to
download and find out for yourself thank
you to hanai Star rail for sponsoring
today's video prepare to receive
modified messaging
[Music]
survey okay the whole Funtime gang is
out to play tonight keep an eye on foxy
there are quick use Mr Cupcake to lure
chica to either side of the office this
will stop others from reaching you but
be careful chica is hungry oh good all
right so what do I do about you was it
like place on one side or the other am I
going to die horribly and quickly that
is the question of the day hi what
is oh Funtime foxy that's right that was
a whole thing what was that about chica
woo that's not good oh wait but but what
do I do about that oh God you're all on
the right side
okay so do I have to switch this I'm
going to switch oh oh
no oh
no okay I don't know what that was
about okay we're fine
what what I heard a donk like someone
just slammed in into the other thing oh
boy that's not good is it I'm going to
just
wait oh God oh
[Music]
God you gone
ow don't know why the boundary is so n
what what do you what what huh
okay all right this is going poorly but
not that poorly
could be going worse okay so you're over
there so that's good so I whoa what was
that about a donk someone someone donk
me just now okay so if I I'm guessing
that's how that works I need to move the
cupcake over to the other side when
chica gets too close oh you're getting
close okay why does that keep sticking
over to that camera oh you're both there
fascinating what if I do that oh
oh God okay so did you come
down oh God you know what think you
might have been
oh oh oh
oh
oh what the freak was that you know what
I think I'm going to face this way I
know I've given a lot of love to this
camera but that's why I have this this
one and so if I face this way I can
actually reach out and do this properly
right people think that they can get the
jump on me but they can't so long as I
can press the right buttons in the right
how close am I I am close to death
there hold
on damn
it damn
it okay no damn it
all right this is good enough good
enough good enough okay you're coming
out you're over there you're over there
you're over
there keep on so what does that
mean is
that what I don't know what that means I
don't know what that's
about and you're about to charge down so
I got to quickly look at which hallway
you're coming down after you move
basically okay we're good there good
there all
right come
on so I'm betting does he always come
down the
left oh my God don't do that oh
God I didn't see anything happen so I
don't know if I don't know if that was
good or not okay so H yeah you did do
that you just Chuck you Chuck your
friend over Yonder
way okay you're coming that way so if I
put you over there so you don't block
foxy that doesn't block foxy it doesn't
seem to
anyway okay well that's so I
have do I have
time okay oh boy oh God oh my God okay
let's move that over there you're clear
now okay getting sort of a handle on
this Freddy gives a little
time so I don't have to slam the door
right away when Freddy is there I think
I
give a little bit of leeway but foxy can
and will come down whatever route that
he chooses so that's something to
consider so you're over
there not well I mean I'm good on
battery so I guess I don't really need
to worry about that too much no
okay either he's throwing uh bon bon
or you
know he's throwing some kind of feal
material okay you go the other side you
go the other
side shoot oh God which way I'm closing
both of them I don't know which way
there he
is God damn you're
quick okay we're okay oh my God oh okay
waiting all right and you're waiting so
what was that about you having oh wait a
minute oh wait a minute that's
weird
huh so the
door or the drawer is
locked but why can you come down that
way right there okay I just don't want
chica to get too close I know it's
probably okay
I don't know what to
expect oh my God who's do okay you just
do that okay you do
that so this isn't too bad I think I'm
going to get through this no problem
it's just foxy that's the Rogue element
okay you're over there over
there perfect great wonderful incredible
outstanding
Beyond Compare
to anything I've ever
endured
[Music]
H I know I don't have to do that but
I've got so much power at this point I
could close all the doors and probably
still make it I'm not going to do that
because that would be
dumb oh boy here we go closing all the
doors except for that one unless foxy
can come charge and oh boy
okay Chica and we win and we've won but
why is this still locked
up
[Music]
oh
wait we did it
y yippee
Wahoo oh well that's nice okay so we got
to start solving the puzzle right the
puzzle is everything right now we don't
know exactly what they're trying to tell
us and by we I mean me but also you
because we're all part of this and we're
all in this together and with Matt Pat
retiring I think the burden of lore
falls upon me from here on out so
everything I say now well I mean this
was true already but everything I say
about Five Nights at Freddy's is now
true and valid that meat Pretzel was
delicious that is an that is my first
declaration as new Lore Master not only
am I the king I am the Lord of lore now
something like that too
soon it's a heavy burden and one I am
only too happy to bear no not happy
about
that but honestly like you know it is
sad
hello you going to give me a number wait
a
minute 1 2 3 4 5 6 there's six cards
here I'm willing to
bet that something about this see that
keypad it needed six numbers there's six
cards here you were telling me clues
about things to do something about in
the the sky not 100% sure
what but there definitely was
something okay fascade I've got a lot of
fascade stuff okay I definitely am going
to do it this way because swinging out
to the sides was not going well for me
don't hit helpie ignore the eyes they'll
distract you from a high
score I'm sorry the machine malfunctions
quickly repair it by inserting the wires
in the correct sequence I'm glad that's
my responsibility okay I'm
ready whoa what did I just do I
know come on out helpie get a helping a
wuming SK won take that helpie ooh wham
wham wham take that
helpie what's that pain yes obliterate
Bam Bam
Bam ch
ch take that
helpie oh oh oh oh
um okay all right okay
[Music]
um all right so
um
I guess I can't hit helpie now so the
actual answer is I can only hit helpie
so many times that's the real answer
here right I think so so I can hit
helpie but I got to keep it to like
three times
Max all right help me you win this time
that's my one that's my
one shut up
okay I I I earned that one I'm way
ahead chk chk
chk okay see I can hit helpie a few
times and everyone's happy especially
helpie I'm
ready
[Music]
there we go see I don't even need to
worry about anything
it's all in the cards wow oh sweet I
don't even need that much more for the
next
one chunk
chunk don't let the eyes distract
you oh boy
it's pretty good not going to
[Applause]
lie I didn't have to fix the machine at
all oh
[Music]
boy h
oh oh oh
tilt oh wait a
minute oh 5761 okay okay
five oh okay
five there we go give me my paddles back
thank
you w that's a lot of helpie to wall
up
yeah I'm getting all of the
helpy couldn't hide from me help
me here we go that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm talking
about the score I can be proud
of H
all right what do you
got oh
Mallet that seems like it would be
useful for
something like Breaking something not
sure what though something has
changed a message for
you games of skill the games of skill
eh
message
message oh tilt bonab
Bon wait but I
did didn't
I it has to be in the other area to tilt
it right because there must have been
something in
there that did that right cuz this is
the only place that's tilted before and
that wasn't a thing that I did that was
a scripted event so logic Al speaking
this must be controlled by
that okay 2011 not
[Music]
[Applause]
bad tilt
[Music]
tilt
tilt okay so now that we've tilted what
do we
do is there something else in here that
we need to know about
3257 is that
important or is it more important to do
that in the other
one some kind of
laughing
oh maybe I was right and it was the
other way to do it was
correct cuz this is saying tilt bonab
Bon why is it
backwards that's the question why is
that backwards
oh headset battery low
oopsies okay well that's a problem let
me quickly how much headset battery I
got o not a lot 17 okay that might be
just enough to try this again in the
normal world and get to the part where
it would tilt and maybe I just need a
high enough score and that'll cause it
to
tilt
damn it
helpy I was aiming for the other one
helpie you can't blame me for that
what what I don't have the headset
battery for this I got to get through
this okay we got this this time not
going to get me oh that's not good
hold
on it's just like I hit it multiple
times but it's not counting it as three
hits damn
it take that helpie you were helping the
enemy damn it a God I'm too close to
that take that helpie
You're In
Cahoots okay let me fix
this it's almost
there God damn
it I'm trying to tilt this
thing damn it I tried to stop
helpie it's just too
hible
[Applause]
I missed him that's the only reason you
survived there
[Applause]
helpie okay 182 is that enough to tilt
it tilt
it til
that no no bonus round okay whatever so
it must be in the other one but I don't
know what that means okay I'm going to
charge up my headset real quick I'll be
back once I get this charge and maybe
I'll figure out how to do this okay BRB
okay we're back in business all right so
where were
we
so
all right
so oo where am I oh where am I we've got
a
conundrum a tough puzzle then that
requires a this is
absurd how is
that how is that what you think that's
what I want
how okay I guess I'm looking this way
now all right whatever so I can't tilt
it in this world so it only tilts here
there's nothing over there now except a
pile of garbage but that's a different
thing because the pile of
garbage is
here it shouldn't be that hard ah man
and then you what are you balora looks
so
happy
maybe maybe it has nothing to do with
bora's gap
saler because balora is
also
in this one right isn't balora in this
one wait not that one this
one in this
one oh wait whoa whoa that's
different okay I've got a few things
that I need to address
but okay let's one thing at a time I
came here to do one thing specifically
and that that was that one let's not
jump around because if I jump around I'm
going to get lost okay so I have an
idea remember when I asked why is it
backwards H okay hold that in your mind
hold that in your
mind you live for now
helpy n now yeah tr
get
okay so well that's a good score that's
what happens when I don't hit LP
apparently but hold it in your head and
your big thick
skull
because
right why would it be
backwards sorry
[Applause]
Elie
died there not
today get back in your demon
hole okay all
right a pretty good score that's not bad
I'm getting better at
this tilt tilt tilt tilt
[Music]
whoa what the freak was that you live
okay
tilt
[Music]
so 1 2 7 3 so let's put
three
seven seven which one's seven can't tell
two is green
bam oh oh my God what the freak are you
whoa oh my God what was
that oh my God what was
that hold
on you were in the way I can hardly not
hit you when you're in the
way
256 hey that's pretty good very
computerized score I don't know what
that hand was oh yeah it's a little it's
okay I just need it a little bit all
right so with
that there should be
[Applause]
theoretically
yippe Yi yippe did that do
it ooh oh oh that's creepy oh hi how you
doing good to see you how you
be you
good creepy I can't grab you can
I
okay okay okay okay that's good that's
good then that
means that these are literal
Clues so there's some
literalness that one was backwards which
meant put the code in backwards this is
a trash
can which means that chica is trash and
this one is balora
dancing which
means you
know yeah I'm thinking it's balor's
Gallery but
also
Bora had a level
here with puppet master I
believe and this is where the thing is
unlocked yeah
and wait is it four
codes hm wait a
minute
oh god oh fre oh right the
power why who who's doing that okay Bora
come at me come at me try me try me
try all right so I don't know the answer
to that just yet but what I do know is
that there are Clues here and there's a
few mini gamess left there are so I
might try to do that in the next episode
but I got this nightmare thing and
thinking about this 1 two three four
five
six one two so there so there
are six
locations here it's either it's either
with the cards here or is there a number
do you have a number no no number okay
there's something there I'm going to
figure it out next time who am I talking
to you thank you so much for watching
let me know at the comments say let me
know what they say look down there is it
Bots probably Bots report them report
those Bots thank you and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye